if ever there was a symbol of a country
on the brink of breakdown this hospital
must surely be it
every morning when i came in hospital
i couldn't be today
the hospital will promise
the medics say they hadn't been paid for
three months
foreign reserves have been frozen since
the taliban took control four weeks ago
most health workers are too scared to be
identified many have left and medicines
are quickly running out
it means difficult decisions this 16
year old is in a coma after being
drugged by rapists and then abandoned by
his parents the doctor tells us he's now
waiting for death for lack of drugs and
he urged the world not to forget
afghanistan
it's not good
to left behind afghanistan people
they need to support afghanistan they
need to support this doctor they need to
support me i'm a professional
every day people spend hours trying to
withdraw their own cash and whilst the
international community works out how to
help ordinary afghans without
bankrolling the taliban the people are
suffering
[Music]
to pay our own money
those money so this
problem for the people not for the
government
the government people receive but look
at these people
they do not have a food at home now
some of the shops remained closed after
persistent rumors about power struggles
at the top of the new taliban government
and worries that this will lead to
fighting between rival supporters
accusing us of being too negative about
the new rulers
they're more keen on showing us the last
government's failures and taliban
fighters are now camped in the mansion
which was home to the former vice
president dostum
they've painted white taliban slogans
over pictures of the warlord who was
notorious for his brutality as well as
his lavish lifestyle
as well as a swimming pool and sauna the
mansion also has a tropical greenhouse
and to the taliban this sums up the
endemic corruption of the previous
government
they were very bad people who lived here
the nation was hungry and he made a
castle for himself and apart from this
one he had more castles
he could have given this money to the
nation and there would have been no
poverty
the talibans afghanistan has little
trade and less aid and without a big
injection of both quickly life won't be
getting better anytime soon alex
crawford sky news kabul